[Music]
if you look closely at this pack of
riders in the Tour de France you'll see
some of the best cyclists in the world
there here in the back they're keeping
up but also resting while their
teammates in the front do most of the
work it's a technique called drafting
and it's what helps them survive the
three-week race around France but
drafting only really makes a difference
on these parts of the route the long
flat and hilly stages eventually these
riders reach stages where they won't be
able to rely on others they have to rely
on their own strength and endurance to
win the race that happens here on the
climbs they're the most brutal and
exciting parts of the race and they're
what makes the Tour de France the most
famous bike ride in the world
[Music]
the Tour de France began as a desperate
ploy to sell more copies of the sports
newspaper law to the paper were
struggling so 1903 its editor on read a
garage organized a nineteen day 2,400
kilometer bike race around the country
it went on to become such a success that
Lauda made it an annual event year after
year they added new routes to make the
tour more challenging and also more
interesting for people to follow by 1908
lottos sales had more than doubled then
in 1910 one of dis ground riders
Alphonse 10a suggested adding a new
twist to the route the tormal a it was a
brutal nineteen kilometer uphill climb
ascending fourteen hundred meters to the
summit to see if this was even possible
stenz jumped in his car to make the
climb he drove up but his car got stuck
in the snow at the top
he suffered from hypothermia and nearly
died but nonetheless he sent a telegram
saying normal a crossed very good road
perfectly passable so the tormal a made
his debut in the 1910 Tour French
cyclist octave Louise was the first to
make the climb successfully but he had
to walk up some parts and famously
called officials assassins when he
reached the summit so he went on to win
the whole tour and his statue was placed
at the top of the tour Millay since then
climbs became a staple of the Tour de
France this year the route is made up of
21 stages over 23 days it features 30
major climbs seven of them are in the
tour's most difficult category
including the tormal a which is part of
the event for the 86th time more than
any other climb in the tourist history
these climbs are where the tour is
ultimately won or lost these are the
long flat and hilly stages that are
usually about 200 kilometers long
here cyclists ride together in a
formation called a peloton it allows
cyclists to save energy by sitting
behind another rider or drafting at high
speeds riders use most of their energy
to pedal against wind resistance but
when a rider stays close behind another
they're sheltered from much of that so
pedaling becomes much easier and they
can keep up with the front riders the
way to measure this is to look at how
much power a cyclist generates here at
the front of the peloton a Tour de
France rider will generate at least 300
watts of power I jumped on a bike to see
what that feels like and just two
kilometers holding 300 watts was really
really hard by comparison when a rider
is behind the lead in the peloton they
only need to generate about 240 watts to
move at the same speed holding 240 watts
for two kilometers felt remarkably
easier so even though these two might
finish a 200 kilometer flat stage at the
same time one is going to be way less
tired than the other that's why you see
some of the tour's best riders here in
the back they're drafting up their
teammates whose job it is to do the hard
work now so that the team's best cyclist
is rested for the most difficult part
the mountains where they'll have to be
on their own
when the peloton starts pedaling uphill
it slows down at this stage the race is
less about fighting wind resistance and
more about gravity which affects all
riders the same way in the peloton so
now every rider in the front and the
back needs to generate an extraordinary
amount of power to keep up pace in 2010
for instance Danish cyclist Chris anchor
Sorenson made it to the front of the
pack on the tormal a climb look at the
facial bruising consolidation out the
pain at the front end as the lead he
dictated the pace of the whole group
this chart shows his power output on the
final climb he averaged 415 watts for
more than 11 minutes face of Chris Anka
Sorensen now really dishing out the
paper and around here he peaked at an
incredible 590 once to mafic riding by
Chris a Kasasa but how long can he keep
this up now look at American cyclist
Chris Horner even though he was several
positions behind Sorenson his power
output was almost the same the faster
Sorenson climbed the harder it was for
the rest of the peloton to keep up and
so the formation started to break up as
weaker riders fell behind this is the
moment in the race when the tour's best
riders switch from drafting to relying
on their own strength to get ahead the
race is breaking up behind them like two
of the best riders here Luxembourgian
Andy Schleck and Spaniard Alberto
Contador who were coasting in the back
of the peloton during the long flat
stages but here they are halfway up the
tormal a Breaking Away for the win each
likely generating well over 400 watts
for the final eight kilometers
Contador in the yellow jersey was the
overall Tour de France leader but only
by eight seconds in second place was
Schleck who would try and lose him on
this climb it was neck-and-neck to the
very top
SiC on the right Contador slack wins
Contador takes second slick edge
Contador by a hair at the top of the
tormal aide to win the stage but since
he didn't lose him
Contador kept his overall lead and went
on to win the Tour de France this kind
of drama is only possible in the
mountains and this year's route makes
climbs particularly important this
year's Tour is being called the highest
in history because of how many climbs
there are over the course of three weeks
just one day features seven climbs even
after more than two weeks in the race
riders climbed a two thousand seven
hundred and seventy meters above sea
level where the thin air makes climbing
even harder that's what makes the Tour
de France the most grueling and
prestigious race in this sport the
winner isn't simply the strongest rider
but the one who endures the most pain
and ultimately has what it takes to
conquer the mountains
[Music]